débattre autour des grands enjeux
économiques de demain c'était l'objectif
de cette réunion publique organisée à
l'hôtel de ville de mort pas parmi les
thématiques abordées la formation
professionnelle les nouvelles
croissances et le revenu universel un
engagement au programme de frédéric
lefebvre candidat à la primaire de
droite
d'abord parce que je défends le revenu
universel et qu'on m'a invité pour en
parler parce que je pense que le vieux
modèle social français est usée jusqu'à
la corde dans moins de dix ans pourra
plus payer les retraites ni donc il faut
faire quelque chose il faut éradiquer la
pauvreté
il faut lutter contre le chômage le
parti libéral démocrate est à
l'initiative de ce débat public
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
sous l'étiquette des républicains est
venu défendre sa vision libérale de
l'économie
on se bat beaucoup sur notamment l'impôt
sur la plus value il faut il faut se
mettre au niveau européen il faut une
convergence fiscale de beaucoup d'impôts
il faut qu'on soit là même compétitivité
que nos amis européens sinon voila sinon
va revivre des moments très difficiles
donc il s'agit de simplifier la vie des
entreprises
hmm hmm également la vie de l'entreprise
l'organisation le code du travail tout
comme le républicain frédéric lefebvre
le parti libéral-démocrate et depuis peu
engagés dans la course présidentielle
avec la candidature de rama yade
le parti libéral démocrate défend une
candidature qui était annoncé jeudi
dernier celle de rama yade et donc on
est derrière rama yade qui est en train
de d'avoir une vision très rénovatrice
et de la politique pour déverrouiller
cette démocratie que beaucoup de
français aujourd'hui contestées il
critique et puis déverrouiller aussi
tous les monopoles les réglementations
les bureaucraties qui noir ça le
quotidien la prochaine réunion organisée
par le pld tournera autour du régime des
indépendants le rsi elle aura lieu le
lundi 9 mai à paris